president biden finally paying attention
to out-of-control violence he's coming
to new york city next week to meet with
mayor eric adams to talk about gun
crimes it only took a surge in
lawlessness in scenes like this to catch
his eye
chaotic video shows a brazen suspect
opening fire in a hospital emergency
room
but i guess if you're going to get shot
that's a great place to get shot you got
to admit you're already in the hospital
the uh the er was thrown into lockdown
and leaving the victim injured cops
nabbing the shooter later on that night
meanwhile actor michael rappaport you
remember him remember him yes i left
stunned after filming a shoplifter
robbing a drugstore
stunned yo that this dude is
i can't believe
i'm seeing
this
guy just filled his two bags up
with everything
in rite aid right here on
80th and 1st avenue is walking down the
street like is gucci i think we found
the first or the only person left in new
york who didn't know about this
happening i mean how do you not know
this happening it's every single day so
judge what drives me nuts about this
stuff it's always about combating gun
crime but never the gun man it's like
they have a biological resistance to
criminalizing the criminal and instead
they put all this emphasis on this
inanimate object which never solves the
problem well that's because guns jump
out on their own and decide who to shoot
they don't need a person behind them
this is so stupid it aggravates
s-t-o-o-p-i-d
s-t-o-o-p-i you've been listening good
for you jesse here's the bottom line for
joe biden to say he's going to come to
new york and he's going to help us out
with gun violence this is a guy who was
silent the whole year before when he was
running for president well they were
burning down businesses and everything
was mass chaos there were shootings
going on not one word came out of his
mouth and they're saying no he's not
he's not in favor of defunding the
police i've never heard him say we need
to fund police and now he's going to
come in and show us how it's done no we
know how it's done this is a political
ploy all it is is democrats getting
together saying we're going to be tough
on crime new york state by the way has
uh the gun possession is lower than in
many states that have literally zero
drive-by shootings so in they want to
change the laws the only laws you need
to change are bail reform giving judges
the ability to have discretion to keep
someone in jail right and you need to
make sure that you follow through and
clear these gun cases exactly
enforcement enforce the rules how does
i'm pounding the table dana our new
table by the way that we haven't even
mentioned a brand new table beautiful
and also an interesting fact uh jesse
did pilates this morning you did yes but
let's start on this table let's stick to
the story at hand
are you talking how does ending gun
violence dana stop the smash and grab
shoplifting the subway shovings the
random stabbings
they they focus on one thing because
they can somehow push it on to like the
nra or something i was wondering today
so who called who did eric adams call
and say joe biden would you please come
to new york and help me figure this out
absolutely did not happen right so what
joe biden's team has realized is that
crime is serious because they're looking
at the polls right they're seeing the
media coverage and not just on fox
everywhere the crime is up and 81 of
people said they were worried about
crime so they realized we got to do
something so we've got the shiny new
penny up there in new york let's go and
deal with that and talk about guns but
when we asked jen's hockey on america's
newsroom about whether the president
would take on
liberal prosecutors
she's like oh no like no like that we're
gonna let them do their thing but we can
give money money is great like i'm sure
that the cops would love more resources
that's great that's not the issue one
thing that would actually be helpful on
the smash and grabs is to deal with the
fact that all of these people can go and
then resale it resell all of those items
online with no penalty so there might be
something there that the government
could actually do that would be helpful
on that thing but they have to be
arrested they can't it can't be
misdemeanors uh when you're having a
shot like that like this guy walking out
this way yeah i still can't find out
where they sell them online because i've
been looking because you know what
blades are really expensive you know uh
jesse he was leva ravaport was leaving a
drugstore that is now closing for good
because they can't keep up with the
robberies which hurts elderly people
like rap report who go there for their
medications elderly you know he's like
he's your age no i think he's in the 70s
is he really interesting no way okay but
these all
so my point is these drug stores all
they're doing is just closing right why
don't they can they do something else to
stop this greg the security guy that was
standing there watch the guy leave with
the goods he's not allowed to touch him
he's so why is he standing there with a
security jacket it's incredible is he a
mannequin is he a model well i mean he's
not it's full-size that's all because of
insurance if you're going to say that
security if you can't do anything about
it and the hospital situation this you
guys got to believe how bananas this is
the guy comes into the er
for an asthma situation and he brings
his mother right and he sees a guy
across the er and the guy gave him a
dirty look
so he unloads like six rounds into this
guy and then runs out of the er and
leaves his mother there
gets back to the apartment in the bronx
and then the sister calls the 9-1-1 and
says my brother's hearing voices and
he's got a gun and they catch him
because he signed his name when he went
and it turns out the guy's been arrested
greg 15 times absolutely for gun
possession narcotics burglary assault
you name it and the guy that was shot
for giving him a dirty look
was shot last year as well for giving
someone else a dirty like
i swear to god he must have quite a look
i swear the guy's got nasty ones on his
face
only only in new york right
meanwhile probably we keep being told
that mayor adams is going to be
different but his proposals still sound
a lot like de blasio no he's bringing
back plain clothes he's he's really i
think re-energizing
and uh enabling cops again i i think
what disturbs you so much here and i am
similarly uh uh
really outraged by it uh a hospital is a
place of curing yeah it's a way you go
when you're hurt you go to the hospital
the hospital is you know wherever the
chaos is in the world when you go to the
hospital you go in there to get better
to sort of see someone bring that
violence and and imagine how traumatized
all the other patients were there in in
the uh in the emergency room so that and
the fact that uh the drugstore on 80th
and first avenue which is
it you know that's not the ghetto that's
that's the upper side that's where all
the the flight attendants live a lot of
the teachers live there
how do you know about that overnight
many times
yes it's like 15 minutes from laguardia
so yeah so to see a see a security guy
basically be blind to that brazenness
breaks the rule what's the rule the rule
is that you society civilization has
certain norms you you know you you don't
steal you don't do all the other things
in the 10 commandments but
to see that
happen so brazenly with so little
consequence is really outrageous i think
that what you need is a whole thing
excuse me i just want to say this one
you need a whole system of passive
aggressive law enforcement surveillance
cameras on every corner you need
everybody should get freering.com from
the from the government uh insurance
companies should not be allowed to
encourage security to turn their backs
on perpetrators is what they what they
do to lower the premiums okay uh you
know i just think yeah all right let me
tell you what the bottom line is here
the bottom line is that alvin bragg came
into office and said i'm not going to
prosecute people who go and hold up
people with guns and ar-15s and if they
steal thousands of dollars of
merchandise i'm going to charge them for
like stealing a dvd that's where the
problem is
period i still say the real crime in all
of this jesse doing pilates
we'll discuss that
in detail no we won't hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else